kennen Sie dieses mulmige Gefühl wenn
man am Bahnhof auf einen Zug wartet
relativ dicht an den Gleisen steht und
denkt was wäre bloß wenn ich jetzt
Stolper ja was dann als genau dieses
Szenario einem Mann in Hamburg wirklich
wieder fährt reagiert ein junger Mann
blitzschnell und unter höchster
Lebensgefahr jetzt ist der der Held von
Hamburg
es sind Augenblicke die überleben und
Tod entscheiden die Überwachungskamera
in der Hamburger S-Bahn filmt wie ein
offensichtlich betrunkener Mann dicht am
Gleis entlang geht das Gleichgewicht
verliert und ins Gleisbett stürzt das
bedeutet akute Lebensgefahr viele
Menschen bemerken den Sturz doch sie
schauen nur Handeln nicht anders er
shiban schandra mit uns ist er zurück am
S-Bahn Gleis wo er nach einer Partynacht
mit Freunden um 2 Uhr ein Menschenleben
rettet
[Musik]
ich habe aus dem Augenwinkel gesehen wie
eine Person auf die Gleisen gestürzt ist
wird sich tief gehandelt reagiert
einfach ein Körper hat ja von alleine
bewegt gehabt Shiva sieht aus dem
Augenwinkel wie der Mann stürzt
geistesgegenwärtig reagiert der
18-Jährige und springt umgehend
hinterher ins Gleisbett bringt sich so
selbst in Lebensgefahr und dieser
Erinnerungen kommen auch heute wieder
natürlich freue ich mich dass ich ein
Leben gerettet habe das ist ja klar ich
habe ab und zu immer noch mulmiges
Gefühl ich denke mir auch manchmal was
wäre wenn die Bahn paar Sekunden früher
gekommen ist was hättest du gemacht
werden die Person wenn du nicht retten
könntest und auch selber mit drauf
gegangen wärst aber es wird glaube ich
mit der Zeit leben und ich bin immer
wieder bereit um eine Person zu retten
die Bilder der Überwachungskamera zeigen
deutlich schiebammen reagiert
blitzschnell er schnappt sich die
gestürzte Person und wuchtet sie hoch so
das helfen der Hände die Person
entgegennehmen können nur Sekunden
später fährt die Bahn in den Bahnhof
rein
5 Sekunden früher kommen und nicht mehr
reingesprungen bis ich auch nicht wie
das geendet hätte aber zum Glück ist es
halt so nicht passiert sondern ich hatte
auch noch genug Zeit um rauszukommen
aber das habe ich auf jeden Fall auch
geschockt dass die Bahn nach in wenigen
Sekunden gekommen ist es sind Bilder die
sich Shiva noch einmal gemeinsam mit
Thomas Hippler von der Polizei Hamburg
anschaut ich möchte mich auf ihnen aus
aller herzlichste bedanken das war eine
tolle Leistung diese gemacht haben und
ja
sie haben das Leben dieses Menschen
gerettet Dankeschön noch bevor shivan
und der Verunglückte Mann wieder auf dem
Bahnsteig sind sind die Lichter der
heran rauschenden Bahn zu sehen mit
Hilfe seiner Freunde kommen shiban
wieder raus aus dem Gleisbett kaum steht
er wieder auf seinen Beinen ist die
S-Bahn da
an der Situation war richtig das hat
schon mal geholfen hat
was man hätte besser machen können ist
einmal noch mal kurz drüber nachdenken
damit man sich selber nicht in Gefahr
begibt und andere Reisende die auf dem
Bahnsteig stehen in die Sache mit
einzubinden einem zu sagen gehen Sie
bitte zur Notrufsäule setzen sie Notruf
ab im anderen zu sagen einmal Handy
nehmen Notruf fehlen und dem dritten
sagen einmal bitte auf den Bahnsteig in
Richtung S-Bahn laufen anstatt nicht
verlassen und den Triebfahrzeugführer
durch Handzeichen warnen den unbekannten
Mann aus dem Gleisbett hat Shiba nach
dem Abend nie wieder gesehen und auch
nichts von ihm gehört von der
Bundespolizei ist der tapfere Hamburger
für seine heldenhafte Tat geehrt worden
bezahlst du mich jetzt nicht richtig als
Held sondern ich habe einfach
Zivilcourage geleistet ähm für manche
Leute bin ich enthält auch viele
Nachrichten bekommen privat dass sie
mich als Held sehen aber ich selber
würde einfach nur sagen dass ich eine
gute Tat verbracht habe der einzige
Wunsch des lebensretters eine Ausbildung
bei der Polizei die Bewerbung ist schon
abgeschickt und diese Bilder zeigen doch
als macht er einen tollen Job
[Musik]